[Music]
daddy's home is what Sean Lowe is
hearing these days a proud papa has a
very unique spot in fact for history
because John is actually the only
bachelor to ever marry the woman he's
hit egl lines at Lauren's diva visited
them at their Dallas home to find out
the secret to their success does it blow
your minds thinking about the fact that
you guys did meet on The Bachelor I
think at least once a week I'll say can
you believe we met on a TV show because
we live such a normal life
when we think about it it's like are you
kidding me it's like kind of like online
shopping to me
cuz I saw him on TV and I was like I
want him and then I got him how many
hours of actual quality time would you
guys say that you spent together on The
Bachelor oh yeah I think like 70 hours
maybe that's I put it said a lot left
three days so after spending not even
three full days together Sean proposed
on the season 17 finale the couple tied
the knot in a televised wedding and have
been married for three years and last
July
they welcomed two son Samuel I think
part of our success comes from the fact
that we've we're not the typical
bachelor couple you know we don't do a
lot of the bachelor reunions that's just
that's just not us
but adjusting to life after The Bachelor
wasn't easy in fact one of their
toughest times was when Sean started
filming Dancing with the Stars yeah I
was rehearsing ten or twelve hours a day
so my new fiance was basically just on
her own which was really unfair to her
the promise that he made when we were
engaged was I will tell you I love you
every day
sorry and he has and not only has he
told me he's shown me if I say maybe I
need you to change diaper we do that he
never said no to me once and that's like
as a new mom as a wife like you just
need someone to say like I'll do it yes
Sean and Catherine say they would like
to have more kids five to be exact and
they want to adopt and then we jump they
are busy designing a new line of
furniture called a home by Sean and
Catherine Lowe how would you guys
describe the line um sophistic um
fertile and Sean calls it slow Z low Z
yeah well week Lincoln
oh I'm dirty but you just we want to
fill but there is a one-of-a-kind piece
in their home that's not for sale well I
mean we have the final rose that's frame
we don't want to shy away from the fact
that we got engaged and fell in love on
it on The Bachelor so that's the only
red rose that I will allow in my house
[Music]
you